una camiseta de bebé necesita cuatro
quintos de yardas de tela o cuatro
quintos de una yarda de tela cuántas
camisetas se pueden hacer con 48 yardas
entonces lo que queremos saber es
básicamente queremos decir cuántos
grupos de cuatro quintos de una yarda
podemos hacer con 48 yardas entonces
literalmente vemos esto cómo tomamos las
48 yardas y las dividimos en grupos de
45 de cuatro quintos de una yarda y ver
cuántos grupos salen si nos dan cuatro
quintos de yardas una camiseta de bebé
entonces la cantidad de grupos de cuatro
quintos es la cantidad de camisetas de
bebé ahora cuando dividimos una fracción
solo debemos recordar que es lo mismo es
completamente equivalente a multiplicar
por el recíproco de la fracción xi aquí
tenemos cuatro quintos su recíproco
sería cinco cuartos ahora aún podrían
pensar aquí tenemos un número entero y
una fracción sólo debemos recordar que
cualquier número entero puede ser
expresado como una fracción esto es lo
mismo que 48
1 por 5 sobre 4
ahora podríamos multiplicar esto y
calcular cuánto es 48 por 5 eso dividido
por 4 pero nos darían números grandes y
sería difícil dividir todo eso pero
podríamos dividir en esta parte de acá
podríamos dividir el numerador y el
denominador por 4 podríamos decir esto
será igual a 48 por 5
cuanto sea que de eso / 4 ahora
dividamos el numerador por 4 bueno si
dividimos 48 por 4 nos da 12 lo que sea
que hagamos con el numerador debemos
repetirlo con el denominador entonces si
dividimos cuatro por cuatro nos da 1 y
nos queda 12 por 5 o sea 60
12 por 560 sobre 1 es exactamente lo
mismo que 60 entonces de hecho podemos
hacer 60 camisetas para bebés con 48
yardas si cada una necesita cuatro
quintos de yarda para su confección